the breakneck pace of the Trump
administration intensifies with a new
high States foreign policy move China is
accusing the White House of launching
the largest trade war in history for
slapping billions of dollars worth of
tariffs on Chinese goods this as our
economy continues to boom US employers
adding a solid two hundred and thirteen
thousand jobs last month president Trump
explains why he's taking action against
Beijing I respect China and I respect
President Xi but they've been killing us
five hundred and seven billion dollars
in trade deficits last year 507 who the
hell can lose 500 then you want to do
something about it you get attacked oh
that's not nice that's not free trade
that war was lost on trade many years
ago well Trump is also continuing to go
after Democrats by repeating his attacks
on Maxine Waters and Elizabeth Warren a
vote for John tester is a vote for Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi
and the new leader of the Democrat Party
Maxine Waters she is a low IQ individual
Maxine Waters she's somewhere in the mid
60's I believe let's say I'm debating
Pocahontas right I'm gonna get one of
those little kids and in the middle of
the debate when she proclaims that she's
of Indian heritage because her mother
said she has high cheekbones that's her
only evidence that her mother said she
and I cheekbone all right Jessie choose
carefully you want to go to China
start with the DNA situation a couple of
weeks ago we had our little DNA tests
and we all got them done and I believe I
was 99.9% European and point one percent
sub-saharan African right so that would
be like if I went into college and
claimed I was a minority in order to get
a leg up in the admissions process it's
kind of in a way what Elizabeth Warren's
being accused of doing at Harvard as a
professor mm-hmm I don't know if she has
any Native American blood her her
grandmother said she might have had
Indian blood I'm not sure there's only
one way to prove it I mean looking at
her she looks about as white as Dana
Perino I was a hundred percent year was
a hundred percent dan is the reality I'm
talking about that for two weeks but
listen I don't want to hide her heritage
there's only one way to prove it but the
Pocahontas nickname really has stuck and
she has not been able to shake this same
with the low IQ Maxine Waters and we saw
this nickname deal in the primaries with
you know what was it sweaty Marco or
lyin Ted and these things hard and they
go viral and it's hard for these people
to escape that I mean imagine if I
switch parties to the Democratic Party
what Trump would call me running waters
dirty water sigh that's why I would
never say the name would just so that's
why you have to stay okay
all right so marina what do you make of
the situated on Jesse's soliloquy there
but not really want to talk about China
and the tariff shirt you
I will talk about China and the tariffs
so what's interesting is these tariffs
not just with China but also with Canada
Mexico and the EU have the real
potential to hurt real voters across the
country whether it's soybean farmers in
Indiana who are already starting to feel
the consequences of this so my question
for the president is when he starts to
hear from these states from senators in
the Republican Party who are up for
reelection or other members of Congress
that the tariffs are hurting the voters
back at home will that change his
calculation because the president's
whole theory of the case is if he puts
these really tough tariffs on these
other countries will come and negotiate
and make better trade deals but we
haven't seen any evidence they're
willing to do so so that president's
playing hardball we have no new trade
deals in place and meanwhile there's
great economic news as you mentioned
sure that has the potential to be
undercut in people's paychecks and
wallets if the tariffs continue for some
time it's a political question at some
point not just an economic one for the
president okay well the president dana
has been you know pretty steadfast on
his talking points at about the economy
about the tariffs that he feel there was
unequal bargaining between the United
States and China has been in place
pretty much for you know but 40 years
where these have had these discrepancies
where it feels like we have had sort of
a disadvantage that we've been operating
on and so he's trying to correct that
I'm what do you think about the timing
and the impact on the economy well I
keep thinking that every morning we'll
wake up and find out Oh everything's
solved and everything was a big
agreement overnight and everything's
fine looks like that's not going to
happen the other thing is there's a
piece in The New York Times today that
reiterated the president floating that
idea at the g7 that why don't we just
take all the tariffs off mm-hmm and Ed
full nur of the Heritage Foundation said
that we'd be for that and I'm like well
actually go with that why don't we try
that with our allies he's gonna see most
of them next play anyway when it goes to
the NATO meeting I do think it has the
potential to hurt people it takes a long
time to build market share especially if
you're a farmer a soybean farmer or a
cattle rancher it takes a while and it
can be undone pretty quickly that's why
I hope that it gets done but one of the
reasons that we have a trade deficit is
that we are a pretty wealthy country and
we'd like to buy cheap things and China
makes a lot of cheap things that we like
to buy and I think that a little bit of
this is turned on its head
the other thing I would say is the
president's about to embark on an 11 day
foreign trip yes he's got a lot of great
opportunities but it's also fraught with
a lot of challenges because my rule is
every time a president goes on a foreign
trip something major happens at home yep
so on Monday night he'll announce the
Supreme Court pick and then he'll be off
and he'll go and he'll let the White
House and the Senate try to work on that
nomination and he'll be out out out of
the country I think that's actually a
pretty smart strategy but then always
something else happens at home nobody
knows what it's gonna be okay so we'll
see we're gonna look for that and hear
about it first on the daily briefing
o'clock for sure hello Tyrus hello so
nice to have you back again for another
amazing to be here yeah look we have a
saying where I'm from it's called break
bread or play dead and that's what we're
doing with China we have the high ground
they need us more than we need them and
they've enjoyed a pretty good run of
getting the benefit of making a lot of
money of our expense here's the thing he
knows he's got four aces in his hand
China knows he's got four he's in his
and they're going to and on top of that
the economy is great and in fact Wall
Street shook it off and just kept going
with the new jobs so there wasn't a big
like what was it uh my dear colleague
Richards like wait till midnight and
those tariffs come in it's another one
of those horror movies that's coming
that never actually come midnight it's
in trouble we have time our economy is
good our jobs are good China has a lot
of exports so they need us so this was a
good move and let's just be patient and
see what happens it's not only a trade
policy but it's a national security
strategy with China because when we
brought them into the WTO they abused
the system they dump all these cheap
goods into the United States they
manipulate their currency they don't
allow for an investment they restrict
that very forcefully and they're
building up their Navy big time so all
we're saying is listen you know we need
to contain China and we've got to have
our allies in order to contain China and
protect us workers because you know ever
since China got into the WTO the
American blue collar men and women at
work a lot of long hours in this country
have gotten hammered the wages have gone
down and the jobs have left so Trump
came in to protect those people and one
of the ways to do that is to contain the
rise of China
they're a big global threat there's
gonna be a big class or the great powers
eventually and I would disagree with
Murray you said that you know the our
allies and the people that we've been
you know doing these little terra fours
with haven't really done anything
South Korea caved on autos and and steel
we already have a deal with them no new
deal no they're allowing more imports of
u.s. autos in their country and they
know they're renegotiating current deals
right now the France has agreed to pay
more for the NATO costs Germany Angela
Merkel said the other day didn't get
picked up but she's willing to drop Auto
tariffs - and the u EU and Japan have
now come in and encircled China within
the WTO along our side so I think he is
moving the needle on that but there are
no trade deals that we've seen put into
place he pulled out of TPP he's
threatening to blow up NAFTA and none of
these other countries have stepped up
bilaterally and said we wanted to do a
trade deal with you instead and look
like I think it's gonna take a very long
Everage men and women you're talking
about the blue-collar Americans they're
the ones that are most hurt by a lot of
these tariffs people in the Midwest in
places like Indiana and Missouri and
we're concerned about so there might be
some short-term pain I agree with that
but but is this short-term pain going to
get us to a better trade policy in the
end I think that's the strategy that
most economists across the political
spectrum don't think well I think most
economists said a lot of great things
were going to happen with a lot of the
other trade deals and a lot of jobs left
the country and he said 200 billion in
new tariffs ready to go as well Dina do
you have another comment not really I
mean I think a lot of these numbers get
thrown around and it's like with the WTO
the United States wins 89 percent of the
cases that it takes to the WTO yeah can
we get to 100 percent wins
maybe I mean China is not innocent here
by the long shot and especially when it
comes to intellectual property theft yep
and technology companies they absolutely
should be called on for that but I think
that the place to do this would be with
our allies with NATO but again even that
still is like giving NATO a bloody nose
on the way to a better trade deal I
don't know I mean maybe it'll all work
out I'm hopeful
okay so David is optimistic with her
sunny side up what do you think positive
like I'm patient I play poker I got like
two or three apps on my phone I got no
okay I do the patients at the plate I
wait for the full wait for my pitch I
love when it's like three two and the
pitcher sweated me and I'm like you
should sweat in China sweat you sweat
that's right all right